歡迎收看泛科學新聞
在此誠摯感謝一百位新加入的泛糰會員
謝謝你們挺身而出
讓泛科學得以製作各式各樣的科學內容
我們正在籌備開啟熱力學、通訊
乃至於軍工科技的新系列
也會延續既有的系列
如半導體、能源、宇宙、交通等等
如果大家覺得哪些主題特別值得製作
歡迎留言或寫信告訴我們
如果你剛好就是這些主題的專家
而且願意協助我們策劃
把內容做得更好
也請不要猶豫
趕快讓我們認識你
泛科學也持續徵才
歡迎資淺或資深的科學編輯
加入我們的行列
等你喔
科學家把「薛丁格的貓」
變成了「阿嬤養的貓」
因為科學家懷疑
誒 對
科學家就是一直懷疑
宇宙難道真的那麼蠻橫
禁止某個 size 以上的東西
處於量子疊加態嗎
到底要多小
東西才可以既是風兒又是沙
痾 不是
是既是粒子又是波呢
維也納大學這次用新方法
再次把 size 矜了上去
研究剛發表在《Nature》上
阿嬤物理學家們
準備了由數千到上萬個鈉原子
組成的金屬團簇
質量約 17 萬道爾頓
直徑約 8 奈米
這相當於一個大型蛋白質
在量子疊加實驗中
算是巨貓
但是養到那麼重
在實驗的速度條件下
用德布羅意公式一算
物質波長只有十幾飛米 (fm)
想用傳統雙狹縫抓干涉訊號
根本抓不到
更麻煩的是
鈉小球是金屬
只要靠近實體柵欄
就會被壁虎最愛的凡德瓦力黏住
實驗還沒開始就結束
所以團隊破釜沉舟
乾脆用紫外光雷射的駐波
在空中砌出亮暗相間的光牆
做成「三關卡」的
泰伯–勞 (Talbot-Lau)干涉儀
首先為了不讓環境打散量子態
干涉儀也很變態
腔體真空要約9×10  mbar
比外太空還空
接著第一關
一般實驗要求粒子束又細又直
但三道光柵的第一道 (G1)
功能就像梳子
就算來的粒子束亂七八糟
也能先「梳整齊」
建立空間相干性
讓它們有資格參加接下來的遊戲
第二道光柵 (G2) 是核心
也是一道死亡陷阱
粒子如果撞上駐波的「亮帶」
會被光打到電離
接著被電場踹出束流直接淘汰
只有乖乖「走在暗帶附近」的粒子
才能保持中性繼續前進
等等
既然光柵跟粒子有互動
那不是等於「測量」了嗎
量子態為什麼沒塌縮
的確
撞到亮帶的粒子
量子態是塌縮了
但它們也被踢了出去
而活下來的
我們只知道它們穿過某個暗帶
但不知是哪個
缺乏關鍵的路徑資訊
量子疊加態得以保全
而且 G2 不只是篩選
光場還會透過光偶極力
讓倖存粒子的物質波在不同位置上
「被推快一點、拖慢一點」
這在物理上叫做「刻下相位」
結果就是
波不再像一條直線
而是開始往多個方向展開、彼此重疊
推算出的疊加距離高達 133 奈米
這是粒子本身大小的 16 倍
這代表不是原地糊成一團
而是真的出現相距很遠的「可能位置」
但要怎麼知道
它真的同時走了多條路徑呢
因為第二道光柵後的干涉條紋
也就是像斑馬線一樣的原子密度波
有寫輪眼也看不到啊
所以科學家設了第三道光柵
當成「可動篩子」
科學家拿著篩子掃過去
當篩子的洞對準密度高的地方
通過粒子數就會飆高
再稍微移一下
變成篩子的牆
對準密度高的地方
通過數就會瞬間下降
於是你會看到訊號很規律地呈現
「高、低、高、低」的起伏
還在懷疑的科學家
怕自己被普通影子或摩爾條紋騙到
所以把量子模型跟純經典解釋拿來 pk
花了兩年 看了上千小時的資料
才撈出這個珍貴的規律訊號
這！就是鈉小球
「既是粒子又是波，纏纏綿綿繞天涯」的鐵證
雖然這不是質量最大的量子疊加
但卻是頭一次把空間上
分得那麼開的疊加
推到那麼大的東西上
「宏觀度」指標達到 15.5
比前紀錄高一個量級
證明了至少在 17 萬道爾頓的巨貓上
宇宙沒有喊卡
而且看來貓還能繼續養下去
你覺得何時會撞牆呢
是物理學家先撞牆、GTA6 先出
還是政府總預算先過呢
讓我們繼續看下去
我們總算找到一個理由
可以原諒颱風了
先說
不是颱風假
你知我知獨眼龍也知
全球暖化正在讓海洋「發燒」
造成「海洋熱浪」
珊瑚白化、魚群暴斃
海洋生態系無處可逃
只能等死
但在這個絕望的時刻
國立中央大學潘任飛教授團隊
發現了一個意想不到的救星
這傢伙完全不講道理
沒有精細操作
全是感情與破壞力
他就是氣象界的「天與暴君」
颱風
研究成果剛發表在
《Science Advances》期刊上
故事的起點發生在 2020 年
當時東海深陷嚴重的熱浪中
彷彿被特級咒靈陀艮
拉進「盪蘊平線」
在那個封閉的領域中
高溫就是必中效果
生物苦不堪言
結果巴威颱風就像甚爾突入
二話不說直接開扁
但科學家是怎麼知道的
颱風上面全是雲
怎麼會看得到海面呢
這就是關鍵
遇到颱風雲層
一般紅外線衛星的確沒輒
所以他們利用能把雲層當透明的
微波 OISST 衛星技術
這讓科學家得以用「上帝視角」
穿透厚重的颱風眼牆
看清巴威颱風時
海面溫度的每一個變化
就在這千鈞一髮之際
最強老爸
痾 不是
是颱風
使出專屬大招「垂向混合」(Vertical Mixing)
就像拿著特級咒具「游雲」
在海裡瘋狂攪拌
把深層冰冷的海水暴力地抽上來
數據顯示
巴威這一頓純粹的物理暴打
讓海面溫度瞬間暴跌 7°C
大家都學過比熱、熱量計算
可以感受一下
這是多麼龐大的能量轉移
再加上秋冬季節的助攻
直接讓熱浪進入了長達 8 個月的
強制冷卻期
一路熄火到隔年春天
這案例讓團隊驚呆了
想說這傢伙這麼猛
那其他颱風呢
於是把 2014 到 2023 這十年來
西北太平洋發生的
85 個「颱風撞熱浪」的案例
全部挖出來看
結果發現這不是巧合
每當颱風一進場
就像甚爾突入陀艮領域那一集在重播
數據顯示
在統計的 85 個案例中
99% 的海洋熱浪在被颱風揍過一遍後
領域直接崩壞
宣告解除
而且團隊還算出了一個精準的暴力公式
颱風每讓海水冷卻 1 度
熱浪想要復活
就被迫延後 5 到 7 天
這就意味著只要颱風打得夠狠
就能幫海洋爭取到關鍵的喘息時間
所以說陸地上的我們
把颱風當成災難
但在海裡
對於快被熱死的海洋生物來說
颱風就是那個雖然性格惡劣
破壞力強
但唯一能打破必死局面的「最強老爸」
歹人嘛會做善事
（pháinn-lâng mā ē tsò siān-sū）
但但但雖然甚爾很帥
颱風來襲的時候
請各位陸地生物務必還是乖乖待在家裡
不然最後可能
嗯
也變成海洋生物
哎呀
我們的「能源轉型」會敗給蟑螂嗎
這篇剛發表在
《能源研究與社會科學》的最新研究
(Energy Research & Social Science)
標題不囉唆
直接就寫著
「Green electricity cockroaches」
綠電蟑螂
來自臺大與中研院的研究團隊
分析了臺灣過去八年的綠能發展
他們從司法院裁判書系統裡
透過搜尋12組關鍵字
挖出了 23 個案件、130 隻綠電蟑螂
但有個但書我得先說
因為很多官司一打就是好幾年
如果堅持等到每一隻蟑螂
都被法院認證才寫論文
那這篇報告還有的等
蟑螂也都進化上了火星
所以這 23 個案子裡
其實將近一半未定讞
しかし
臺灣司法的定罪率高達 96.4%
也就是說只要被檢察官起訴
這人基本上就
嗯
所以研究者直接在論文裡寫說
「我們默認被告就是有罪」
好 經過解剖
他們發現這些綠電蟑螂
已經演化出三種變異
第一種是擬態型 擅長詐欺
這類蟑螂最會偽裝
他們會成立空頭公司
假裝有獨家技術、有地皮
把同一個案場的股權
賣給好幾個投資人
把受害人的資源騙光後
才驚覺裡面根本是空的
第二種是寄生型 擅長侵佔
這類蟑螂通常出沒在地方說明會
當村民抗議光電板有問題時
這些官員就會跳出來說
「我是公親，我來撨（tshiâu）」
他們假裝是緩衝
跟廠商拿了幾百萬的「疏通費」
結果錢全進自己的肚子裡
村民一毛都沒拿到
第三種也是戰鬥力最強的
就是力量型 擅長勒索
68% 的綠能蟑螂
都棲息在基層的「鄉鎮公所」
為什麼這麼強？
因為他們手裡握有絕對武器「路權」
你要拉電線？
抱歉 路是我管的
走水溝
我管的
這一小塊畸零地
也是我管的
研究發現
很多廠商根本不想行賄
但佔地為王的蟑螂直接把路堵死
不給錢工程別想動
好 那這些被抓到的蟑螂
到底是什麼顏色的
準備好了嗎
研究發現涉案頻率最高的
不是「民選政客」
而是坐在鄉公所角落
我們叫不出名字的「常任文官」
他們是永遠的 NPC
就算鄉長四年換一個
但建設課長永遠都在
他們大多沒有特定黨籍
不管誰執政
只認錢
所以臺灣的綠能轉型之所以顛簸
不是因為科技
而是因為手握印章的蟑螂
但會有那麼多蟑螂
根源是遊戲設計的太爛
最大的 Bug
就是鄉鎮公所手上的「路權許可證」
學者建議
Nothing beats a cockroach
唯一的辦法就是從制度下手
把審查權從地方收回中央
否則投再多錢都會變成蟑螂飼料
以後只要廠商符合工程標準
系統就要強制發證
再來很多廠商回饋金直接給現金
這...
結果你也猜得到
因此學者建議關閉私下交易功能
所有回饋金必須「法制化」
匯款到公庫專戶
最後學者也建議建立線上儀表板
學線上購物
文件現在在哪一關、卡了幾天
是誰在審
全部顯示在網頁上
看哪個公務員
敢把公文壓兩個月不蓋章
蛤
你覺得蟑螂很可愛
你從來不打
誒 檢察官
這裡有個罪犯
好男人都到哪裡去了
科學家終於給出了答案
紐西蘭奧克蘭大學的團隊
不看網路上關於有毒男子氣概的嘴砲
而是動用了
紐西蘭態度與價值觀研究資料庫(NZAVS)
這可不是隨便什麼
「你覺得你是渣男嗎？」的心理測驗
這是一項國家級的長期追蹤計畫
他們從中隨機抓了 15808 位
年齡從 18 歲到 99 歲的異性戀男性
非常分散
但可能都客串過《魔戒》就是了
為了把這群男人看透徹
不忽略個體差異
研究團隊拋開傳統統計
看的那種全體「平均值」
使用「潛在剖面分析」 (LPA)
LPA 就像霍格華茲的分類帽
看的是「類型」
電腦會同時分析這 15000 多人的
8 種心理特徵數值
包含仇女程度、自戀、是否支持暴力
以及對男性身份的認同感等等
然後比對每個人的數值分佈模式
只要各項指標高低起伏的形狀
跟別人很像
電腦就會判定是同一種人
結果男人被分成五大類
首先是佔了 35.4% 的最大宗
叫做「無毒組」 (Atoxic)
這群人所有負面數值都低到不行
簡直是勇者欣梅爾轉世
再來是兩組中間派
「LGBT 友善組」 (27.2%)
和 「反 LGBT 組」 (26.6%)
這兩群人加起來超過一半
基本上都是普通好人
差別在於前者看到彩虹旗會比讚
後者會碎念兩句
但除此之外他們對女性沒有惡意
接著是比較麻煩的 7.6%
叫做「善意有毒組」 (Benevolent Toxic)
這群人
嗯
他們不一定會罵女生
反而可能對女生超好
但這種好是建立在
「妳是弱者，我是強者」的偏見基礎上
對 有那麼點霸道總裁
但大概都不是總裁
最後才是真正的反派
「敵意有毒組」 (Hostile Toxic)
仇女、自戀、甚至反對家暴防治
但重點是這群禪院家術師
只佔了總人口的 3.2%
令人驚訝的是
我們常以為那些練很壯
整天喊著要當「阿爾法男」 (Alpha Male)
覺得「身為男人很自豪」的傢伙最有毒
對吧
但這 15000 人的資料顯示
「重視男子氣概」跟「有毒」沒有關聯
男人可以是一個對自己性別很自豪的硬漢
同時非常尊重女性
那 3.2% 的劇毒男到底是誰
研究發現這群人通常不是什麼社會菁英
通常是年紀大、單身、失業、學歷低
他們之所以「毒」
往往是因為在社會競爭中被淘汰
轉而用仇恨來武裝自尊
膽小又害怕，心亂如麻，你驚慌茫然無助
所以在森林寧願遇見熊
也不要遇到男人嗎
數據證明好男人很多
起碼在紐西蘭不少
但那 3.2% 聲量很大的害群毒馬
也是要處理一下
不然哪天他們成群結黨
那就...
唉
蛤
已經結黨？
出大事了
根據美國奧克拉荷馬州立大學團隊
在 《PeerJ》 的最新研究
我們過去 20 年來
對暴龍生長速度的理解
竟然全錯
這篇長達 66 頁的報告
全面清算了舊有研究方法
以前做暴龍研究最慘的就是「缺樣本」
全世界完整的暴龍化石就那幾隻
科學家常常得拿親戚
像亞伯達龍之類的數據來擋
或是靠腦補把斷層連起來
但這次團隊集結了 17 隻
純種暴龍的股骨切片
這在古生物學界
等同是把七龍珠、無限寶石
加上 One Piece 都蒐集到了一起
從幾百公斤的暴龍屁孩
到傳說中活到快 30 歲
渾身病痛的老祖母「蘇」(Sue) 共聚一堂
讓人類頭一回
能不靠混血數據
畫出 100% 純度的暴龍生長曲線
不過畫圖前
得解決一個基本問題
怎麼知道恐龍幾歲
以前是把大腿骨切開
數上面的圈圈
也就是 「生長停滯線」 (LAGs)
但恐龍的骨頭隨著年齡增長
骨髓腔會擴大、內部會重塑
就像邊寫日記
邊撕掉前幾年的頁數
很多老暴龍的童年紀錄
全都不見了
aww~
怎麼辦
這就要說到研究的第一個核心突破
光學解密
論文指出恐龍骨頭裡
藏著一種特殊的生長輪
叫做 「XPL-only Annuli」
意思是它們在
普通的平面偏振光下(Plane Polarized Light, PPL)
是完全隱形的
只有在
「正交偏振光」(Cross-Polarized Light,XPL) 下
才會現形
但正交偏振光有個致命傷
視野中央會有個黑色的 「消光十字」
擋住關鍵資訊
於是團隊祭出了新招
「圓偏振光」 (Circularly Polarized Light, CPL)
原理是這樣的
當恐龍長得慢
例如冬天或旱季
骨頭的膠原纖維會排得緊密整齊
產生 「雙折射」 (Birefringence) 性質
而圓偏振光就是去魔改正交偏振光
塞入兩片
「四分之一波片」(Quarter-Wave Plates)
讓光線像鑽頭一樣旋轉
消除了礙眼的黑色十字
讓原本躲在死角的「幽靈年輪」
全亮起來
這一照才發現
以前少算了好多歲
誒 「看見」之後還要解決「看錯」
以前看到好幾條線擠在一起
通常假設恐龍大概這一年狀況不好
停停長長好幾次
這一坨線
那就算一歲吧
但這次科學家引用
大量現代鱷魚和鳥類數據反駁
認為這種密集的「多重紋」 (Multiplets)
其實是連續好幾年的紀錄
這代表暴龍可能三四年
都處於「歹年冬」(pháinn-nî-tang)
才每年只長一點點
如果把三條線合併成一年的話
那可就低估了壽命
也高估了生長速度
把幽靈年輪加回來
把多重紋拆開算之後
暴龍的生長曲線大大拉長了
舊理論認為
牠們 20 歲就長好長滿
然後掛點
新模型顯示
牠們其實一路長到 35 到 40 歲 才停
過去還認為生長最快的那一年
是性成熟期
但這篇論文認為
暴龍身體可能一邊狂長一邊繁殖
新模型要立威
當然要清理門戶
團隊比對了兩隻
一直被當作暴龍青少年範本標本的
Jane 跟 Petey
發現生長模式與真正的暴龍對不上
他們長得太慢
而且在該抽高的 13、15 歲
就不長了
代表他們很可能不是暴龍
而是另一個物種「矮暴龍」 (Nanotyrannus)
所以說單看外表要判斷年齡
是很容易出錯的
就像泛科學的那個...
靠背
我就知道
以上就是本週的泛科學新聞
如果你喜歡今天的內容
或是對哪一則新聞想黜臭
歡迎在下面留言
也別忘了按讚、訂閱、開啟小鈴鐺
下週繼續發現這世界有多荒唐
如果你有拍到什麼
比暴龍還迷人的背景圖
歡迎投稿喔
詳情請看下方的資訊欄
我們下週見